lo que tenemos aquí son dos polinomios
diferentes p1 y p2 y se han expresado en
forma factor izada también podemos ver
sus gráficas
esta es la gráfica de g es igual a 1 de
x en azul y la gráfica de i es igual a 2
de x en blanco lo que vamos a hacer en
este vídeo es continuar nuestro estudio
de ceros pero vamos a ver un caso
especial en el que sucede algo
interesante con los ceros así que veamos
primero los ceros de p1 voy a poner una
tabla que será útil en la primera
columna vamos a poner los ceros los
valores de x en los que nuestro
polinomio es igual a cero y eso es
bastante fácil de calcular en la forma
factor izada cuando x es igual a 1 todo
va a ser igual a cero porque es cero por
cualquier cosa es cero cuando x es igual
a 2 por el mismo argumento y lo mismo
cuando x es igual a 3 y podemos verlo
aquí en la gráfica cuando x es igual a 1
la gráfica de i es igual a 1
ínter seca al eje x lo hace de nuevo en
el siguiente 0 x es igual a 2 y en el
siguiente 0 x es igual a 3 también
podemos ver la propiedad de que en ceros
consecutivos
nuestra función nuestro polinomio
mantiene el mismo signo de modo que
entre estos dos primeros ceros o en
realidad antes de este primer cero es
negativo luego entre estos dos primeros
ceros es positivo entre los siguientes
dos ceros es negativo y después de eso
es positivo ahora qué pasa con pedos
bueno pedos es interesante porque si
fueras a multiplicar esto tendría el
mismo grado que p 1 en cualquier caso
tendría un término con x elevada a la
tercera potencia tendrías un polinomio
de tercer grado pero cuántos ceros
únicos distintos tiene p 2 pausa el
vídeo y piensa en esto bueno vamos a
enumerar los aquí tenemos los ceros una
vez más si x es igual a 1
toda esta expresión va a ser igual a
cero así que tenemos cero cuando
es igual a 1 y podemos ver que nuestra
gráfica blanca también inter seca el eje
x cuando x es igual a 1 y luego si x es
igual a 3 todo esto va a ser igual a 0 y
podemos ver que intersecta el eje x
cuando x es igual a 3 y luego fíjense en
esta parte de la expresión podemos decir
que tenemos un cero cuando x es igual a
3 pero ya dijimos eso así que en
realidad tenemos dos ceros para un
polinomio de tercer grado de modo que
aquí está sucediendo algo muy
interesante de alguna manera se podría
decir que estamos tratando de reforzar
que tenemos un cero en x igual a 3 y
esta noción de tener múltiples partes de
nuestra forma factor izada que apuntan
al mismo cero es la idea de
multiplicidad de jane escribir esta
palabra multiplicidad lo escribiré por
aquí y lo escribiré aquí multiplicidad y
así para cada uno de estos ceros tenemos
una multiplicidad de uno se deducen sólo
una vez cuando miramos la forma factor
izada
uno de los factores apunta a cada uno de
estos ceros así que todos tienen una
multiplicidad de uno para p 2 el primer
0 tiene un múltiplo de 1 solo una de las
expresiones apunta a un 0 en uno o se
convertiría en 0 si x fuera igual a 1
pero fíjense en la forma factor izada
todos de nuestros factores de expresión
se convierten en cero cuando x es igual
a 3 este y éste se van a convertir en 0
de modo que aquí tenemos una
multiplicidad de dos te invito a que
pausa es el vídeo nuevamente y mires el
comportamiento de las gráficas y trates
de ver si hay diferencia en el
comportamiento de las gráficas cuando
hay una multiplicidad de uno y cuando
hay una multiplicidad de dos muy bien
ahora vamos a resolverlos juntos
podríamos mirarte uno donde todos los
ceros tienen una multiplicidad de uno y
se puede ver que cada vez que tenemos un
cero estamos cruzando el eje x y no sólo
lo estamos inter secando sino que lo
estamos cruzando estamos cruzando el eje
x lo cruzamos de nuevo y lo
estamos cruzando de nuevo así que
tenemos un cambio de signo alrededor de
este cero pero qué pasa aquí bueno en el
primer cero que tiene una multiplicidad
de uno que solo hace que uno de los
factores sea igual a cero tenemos un
cambio de signo tal como vimos con p 1
pero qué sucede cuando x es igual a 3
donde tenemos una multiplicidad de 2
bueno ahí ínter secamos el eje x
pd3 es igual a 0 pero fíjense que no
tenemos un cambio de signo
tenemos positivos antes y tenemos
positivos después tocamos el eje x aquí
pero luego volvemos a subir y la idea
general los invitó a probar esto y
pensar porque esto es verdad es que si
tienes una multiplicidad de impar si la
multiplicidad es impar si es 1 357
etcétera entonces tendrás un cambio de
signo cambio de signo mientras que si es
par como en el caso de 24 o 6 no vas a
tener ningún cambio de signo no hay
cambio de signo una forma de pensar en
esto en un ejemplo donde tiene
una multiplicidad de dos vamos a usar
este cero donde x es igual a tres cuando
x es menor que 3 ambos van a ser
negativos y un negativo por un negativo
es igual a un positivo y cuando x es
mayor que 3 ambos van a ser positivos
así que en cualquier caso tienes un
resultado positivo fíjense que no hubo
ningún cambio de signo otra cosa que
debemos notar es pensar en el número de
ceros relativos al grado del polinomio y
lo que vemos es que el número de ceros a
lo sumo es igual al grado del polinomio
por lo que va a ser menor o igual al
grado del polinomio y por qué es así
bueno todos tus ceros pueden tener una
multiplicidad de uno en cuyo caso el
número de ceros va a ser igual al grado
del polinomio pero si tienes un cero que
tiene una multiplicidad superior a uno
bueno entonces vas a tener menos ceros
distintos otra forma de pensar en esto
es que si sumas todas las
multiplicidades entonces eso va a ser
igual al grado de tu polinomio